but on Smallville it was all just I felt
like I was like a boxer who was just
like this all the time yeah you're
always just defending yourself and just
trying to yeah yeah and now you're
trying to survive well let me ask you
this we went to Nashville and we did
this Con and there was this huge tornado
and you know horribly and sadly people
lost their lives well when this thing's
coming at us and the sky is just this
color I've never seen and the alarms are
going off and it's the the warnings are
coming up on your on your alerts on your
what do they call those iPhone alerts
Amber Alerts or Whatever It Is Well
Amber is missing children Oh missing
children it's not that one it's just an
alert and you're in a room and
everyone's phone goes off right so what
I'm saying is they made us all go down
the entire con hotel to the were you
there for what I said to the parking
structure and like it was serious like
Jensen Ackles and me and Tom and Jared
we all went down to the parking
structure with all these fans with all
these people in the hotel and we were
awaiting what instructions on what to do
next and the first thing I was thinking
of now well I actually I'm thinking of
now is you know I'm kind of carefree and
I'm like I'm not worried I'm just like I
well I just have to take care of myself
but at all were you at all thinking were
you worried were you thinking oh you
know I've got these two boys and my wife
at home um did that that occur to you at
all do you ever think of that stuff like
it's so funny because I I literally got
a slap in the face from Kim who works
with us physical or mental no no no it
was it was mental but like I come I come
back to the room you know we're we're
both about to be done for the day which
everybody loves to be done for the day
and uh we get back there the alert goes
off and Kim was like kind of and she
runs the show she's awesome for these
and uh and it was like okay we all have
to go down to the parking garage third
level uh there's a tornado coming we all
need to go and I turn her and I go well
I don't need to go and she goes what do
you mean I'm like I mean and I literally
said to her such a this is so stupid I
go I'm an adult I could do whatever I
want because I was thinking I'm going to
walk back two blocks at the hotel right
and she looks at me and she goes do you
really want your wife to hear that
you're the one person that leaves and
dies and leaves your wife and two kids
and I was like let's go down to the
parking garage so it's like no one's per
you know like cuz I was just like I want
to go I want to go
I don't need to be here you know me I
can one of the things that works for me
at work and this is a sidebar everything
that's wrong with me works on set like
me on set all my everything crazy and
like neotic it all works in life is is
it's more of an adaptation if that makes
any sense so when she's like we all have
to go downstairs we have to go and I'm
like well I don't have to go and then
when she said it to me I was like and I
told my wife this
puts things into perspective hey to the
do the boys ever bring you to tears is
there any something is there something
that you're you know kids were you